[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANISH MALHOTRA: Google
Cloud just moved
into your neighborhood.
Hi and namaste.
I'm Anish.
I lead the customer engineering
team in India and Asia,
helping customers
migrate to Google Cloud.
We're seeing huge demand
for Google Cloud in India,
with customers like Hike,
Dainik Bhaskar, Ashok Leyland,
Inshorts, and Walnut,
to name a few.
This is the reason why
we and our customers
are so excited to see the
launch of a news region
in Mumbai, India.
For the first time
ever, GCP users
can process and
store data in India.
Our services include
Compute, Big Data, Storage,
and Networking.
This new India region
has everything that you
need to build and scale.
It has been an amazing journey
to onboard Hike as a customer.
We're running their entire
infrastructure and analytics
platform in Google Cloud to run
their cross-platform instant
messaging service.
I love working with Inshorts,
who are using Google Compute
Engine to power
their news content
delivery mobile application.
The new region in
Mumbai means speed.
Our performance testing
of the Mumbai region
shows 50% to 90%
reduction in latency
when serving
customers in India, as
compared to other
GCP regions in Asia,
like Singapore and Taiwan.
GCP is the smart
secure cloud that will
move your business forward.
With the opening of
the new Mumbai region,
Google is your new neighbor,
right here, right next door.
[MUSIC PLAYING]